hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
dr. Rocha Ignat over may not be a
household name but among a certain
following she's a superstar she was the
founder and the face of the
cryptocurrency one coin it was dubbed to
be the Bitcoin killer and promised to
revolutionize the way we see money dr.
ruja toured the world speaking to crowds
of people at sold out venues about how
one coin was like Bitcoin but bigger
better and easier to use on the back of
one coin and the three million people
who invested dr. Rocha reached fame and
fortune but suddenly in late 2017
she disappeared without a trace where
did she go what happened what was later
uncovered was a story of greed deceit
fraud and an international scam worth
fifteen billion dollars you are watching
ColdFusion TV
[Music]
stepping onstage to a packed hour crowd
in 2016 and then 36 year old crypto
founder was welcomed with cheers and
applause from endearing fans the song
this woman is on fire echoed through the
Wimberly arena while the lady who stood
on stage was a superstar of sorts she
wasn't a pop singer it was none other
than dr. Raja Ignat / the founder of one
coin and one of the leaders of the
global cryptocurrency movement though
unbeknown to the cheering masses just a
year later she would be on the missing
persons list dr. Raja was a commanding
figure she was extremely intelligent and
knowledgeable and was said to make
high-level bankers look like fools
her arguments were centered around many
of the same ideologies that the wider
crypto movement was based on the idea
that traditional banks and governments
had too much power when it came to
currency and that it was time for a
revolution to democratize money that is
give the power back to the people on the
back of the 2008 global financial crisis
a lot of people were willing to listen
and rightly so on these points she was
actually right the one coin found her
went on to blame the greed of the big
banks for the financial crisis and
ultimately proclaimed that the current
system was old and outdated and their
cryptocurrencies as a whole and in
particular one coin would be the future
but it went deeper than that as dr. Rita
spoke to thousands of investors at
Wembley Stadium
she spoke about joining not just a good
investment and not just a revolutionary
global financial movement but a family
we will be the biggest out there and we
will write history and the
cryptocurrency community will have to
rewrite philosophy
nobody can compare to us we have today
the most users we are the biggest crypto
reserve currency out there and to
everybody who tells me that I violate
the philosophy of cryptocurrency guys we
are a bigger community we decide what
the philosophy of cryptocurrency is in
two years nobody will speak about
Bitcoin any more investors became part
of a network called one life they would
join whatsapp groups with insider
information often being told to ignore
the outside haters they even had their
own hand symbol which people would use
when meeting other members of one life
but despite all of this dr. Raja had the
credentials to mention statement she
studied at Oxford had a PhD previously
worked in McKenzie which is a very
exclusive global consulting group
[Music]
one coin grief fast within three years
of launching there were over 3 million
investors from around the world
conferences and seminars popped up
everywhere from the United States China
and the UK all the way to African
nations each event would at least show a
video of dr. Rocha when she was too busy
to leave her home country of Bulgaria
things were going great for one coin
until late 2017 though earlier in the
year some cracks were beginning to show
in April of 2017 Indian police arrested
18 people in Mumbai for trying to
organize a onecoin recruiting event
though during the sting 11 million u.s.
dollars was transferred out of bank
accounts before the police could get to
it in all of this what was dr. richard
going to do dr. Raja was scheduled to
speak at a one coin seminar in Lisbon
Portugal in October 2017 however she
didn't make it to the seminar this was
unusual as her colleagues noted that she
was extremely punctual she would often
refuse to attend meetings if the other
parties were just a single minute late
her colleagues called her no answer no
messages either no one knew where she
was being the head of a movement as
valuable as one coin comes with its
targets the crypto founder was well
aware of this and walked around with two
bodyguards fears for her life spread who
the room is saying that she was
kidnapped by some big banks or more
optimistically that she went into hiding
from them but the thing is nobody has
seen dr. ruja
since that day
after her disappearance doctor Regis
younger brother constantan had taken her
place at the top of the onecoin Empire
he was previously her bodyguard and
personal assistant a tattooed muscular
figure who was by the previous account
of other employees a bit dim in March of
2019 constantan was about to board a
flight from Los Angeles to Bulgaria
the FBI arrested him and charged him
with money laundering and fraud the same
day US authorities proclaimed one coin
to be a fraud the FBI has secretly
charged the now-missing dr. Raja over
two years ago around the same time she
went missing this raised some questions
had she been tipped off there'll be more
on this later in the episode so what was
one coin in the first place essentially
it was multi-level marketing multi-level
marketing typically uses people to
recruit others who purchase data
packages you make a commission for every
person that you bring into the business
this includes a cut of that person's
future sales including everybody that
they bring into the business
the problem with multi-level marketing
is that it rarely if ever actually
creates any value in the form of a
product or a service fundamentally
people make money off recruiting others
hence a few people at the top make all
the money while the rest lose everything
one coin is sold in the form of
educational packages which contain
tokens which allow you to mine one coins
however there really isn't any mining
going on the blockchain a fundamental
structure of cryptocurrency doesn't even
exist in one coin and the exchange which
allows real money to be traded for one
coin has been under construction for
years and mod would constant delays
though the company will tell you that
they sell educational packages helping
teach people of our financial freedom
each of these educational packages could
cost anywhere from $100 to $100,000
this is how one Queen made their money a
lot of the educational materials in
these packages were later found to be
plagiarized from other sources the
buyers of these packages are told that
the money that they used to buy them
would be converted into one coin which
is guaranteed to go up in value of
course this turned out to be false
perhaps by hiding behind technicalities
and loopholes they've been able to grow
so rapidly and fall under the
legislative radar when you have a
digital product that you cannot touch
like an education package of course
people are more skeptical so on I
respect everybody who has questions or
who criticize or just wants to talk to
us but what I do not like is when people
do not do their homework and do not
check what is going on one coin
retreated the best and most experienced
multi-level marketing sellers to start
the chain and the scheme was far
reaching even as far as Uganda the
seminars Sprouse it all over the world
and brought ever more people into the
get rich scheme sadly some sold their
houses or their farm animals to buy in
just exactly how much did you lose and
what effect has it had on your life I
personally lost ten thousand journalists
and friends collectively war loss has
been two hundred and fifty thousand
euros it has been absolutely devastating
for the unsuspecting person it's not
hard to see how they could be fooled she
wowed the crowds with their
inspirational speeches her credentials
constantly upholding her however not all
was as it seems one of the first Google
image search results that you get from
dr. ruja appears to be her on the front
cover of Forbes magazine here she looks
the part of a pioneering genius but in
reality this wasn't the front cover of
Forbes far from it it was a paid
advertisement in Forbes Bulgaria
magazine the advert appeared halfway
through the magazine next to another
advert selling watches of course it was
just a method to trick people into
thinking Forbes had done a front-page
interview with her
while it remains that dr. Rocha has a
PhD attended Oxford and is undoubtedly
intelligent the careful fabrication of
other aspects of her persona was an
attempt to build authority and
credibility around her hence when she
spoke at events people were not only
enchanted by her words but impressed by
her credibility this is what made buying
one coin look very attractive what were
you told about investing in one coin and
what it could earn you they were told
that it would it's the value of it when
she purchased they bred packages so I
five thousand pound package when you
bought it it turned into a digital
currency value 40,000 that's how it was
approached to you which sounds like an
amazing financially life to enjoy with
its founder finishing off the face of
the earth and the indictment of her
brother who took over the helm the one
coin show must go on
in homage to its glamorous founder one
coin bizarrely held a beauty contest it
was a hastily organised event intended
to promote one coin in a time with doubt
shrouded the company the whole thing was
a very strange affair the top five
contestants won $25,000 of
plastic-surgery vouchers or the
equivalent amount in one coin the
company claimed that it would have an
audience of twenty to fifty million
people and that it was sponsored by
Vogue however this couldn't be further
from the truth
there's only a few hundred people at the
event and Vogue had no idea about the
contest reading the website miss one
life calm grammatical errors can be
clearly seen and it does look like a
run-of-the-mill
internet fraud but regardless it's
amazing to think that this organization
pulled in 15 billion dollars in
investments beneath the smiles the glitz
and glamor lies an uncomfortable truth a
truth that not only reflects individual
human nature but society as a whole such
as our perception of information
Tech age coupled with greed and a herd
mentality dr. Raja is one example of
blowing way to open the floors of the
modern age with so much information
being constantly created on the internet
people don't have time to fact-check
people and companies can openly lie
about facts and get away with it the
small portion of people who find the
truth have a much smaller voice than the
lie that was first told and even if lies
are exposed it's so so easy to blame
fake news haters or simply just put out
opposing content multi-level marketing
which relies on a community and
person-to-person selling can share some
similarities to a cult the people inside
are convinced to believe that the
outside is against this us-versus-them
mentality was one of the reasons that
one coin seemingly continued to go on so
effortlessly to the believers the entire
financial sector and most of the world's
governments wanted to shut down a
revolution many still believe that dr.
Rogers disappearance was for her own
safety as opposed to her scamming
everyone and running away with their
money
so where is dr. Raja well right now
that's anyone's guess her brother and
former bodyguard constantan does reveal
more details however during testimony
after being arrested by the FBI
he states dr. Raja was living in
Bulgaria before she vanished she told
him that she was quote very tired of all
the haters and was afraid somebody close
to her was going to give her up to the
FBI some of the final details we have is
that dr. Rocha bought some plane tickets
to Vienna Austria and then Athens Greece
constantan hasn't spoke to her sister
since she disappeared he hired a private
investigator to find her but this has
been unsuccessful she's wanted by the
United States her brother is in custody
awaiting trial and yet her company is
still somehow functioning with steadfast
believers and new ones buying in each
day according to BBC journalists as much
as 1 million dollars is still being
pulled in each week her lawyer has
recently been found guilty of fraud to
the tune of 50 million u.s. dollars and
is awaiting sentencing it's difficult to
predict where she is however there's a
high chance that she's still alive and
just laying low by accounts of former
onecoin employees her mother was
unnerved by her daughter's disappearance
suggesting that dr. Raja made a
calculated exit as mentioned her last
known travel destination was Athens
Greece though some clue is pointed to by
London and Russia with all of this being
said the wealth she acquired from one
coin may mean that finding her is
impossible saw two things really is
trying to figure out where this woman is
which there are theories like you
wouldn't believe about where she is
what's happened to her and also trying
to took uncover just how she she managed
to pull this off I mean in some strange
way this is a remarkable achievement to
have fooled so many people and then to
have vanished off the face of the earth
this was becoming almost like a religion
doctor
threw one coin has exposed some glaring
faults in society technology is
developing so rapidly that is difficult
to keep up this can generally be a great
thing though on the flip side many
people can be fooled into believing in
technology that don't understand
especially in this day and age with so
many sides to each story and the
emergence of fake news surrounding the
Internet it's easy to get lost in an
echo chamber of confirmation bias today
it seems much more difficult for people
to change their minds and consider
opposing information dr. ruja who is
thought to have run away with four
hundred million dollars may never be
caught some even believe that she's
drastically changed her appearance with
plastic surgery sources say that the
money lost ranges anywhere from four
billion to fifteen billion dollars for
the sake of all of those investors who
were scammed and lost everything we can
only hope that dr. ruja Ignat /
resurfaces somewhere and has to answer
for her misconduct it's such a sad thing
to see happen but the only thing that
can be learned is always do your
research before investing into anything
so thanks for watching this video if you
want to see anything on science
technology business or history feel free
to subscribe there's a lot of content
here on this channel this has been - go
go and you've been watching cold fusion
and I'll catch you again soon for the
next video
cheers guys have a good one
cold fusion it can you thinking
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]